I'm Catherine Fleming the president and
CEO of the J Paul Getty trust in Los
Angeles my name is
philosopher my name is Lisa apignonesi
I'm a writer I've written books on Freud
on women on the history of Madness as
well as fiction and Memoir I'm Stephen
Farthing I'm an artist welcome to my
studio in Carthage I'm Andre tarkovsky
so I'm not a great Russian filmmaker and
seniors myself my name is Emily gorenger
and I'm the director of the farhuk
museum in Amsterdam my name is Umberto
Beck
I'm an essayist and intellectual
historian from Mexico
I'm Valentino vapor and I'm a Mexican
German writer and poet
this year's Nexus conference I'll be
asking questions like what is it about
manko that makes him so popular
why does everyone around the world seem
to love him and by the way why should
you go to museum in this digital age how
is a painting like this which is not so
different from something that van Gogh
might have painted
going to exist in the future technology
is changing very rapidly AI is becoming
a very important part of what goes on in
museums and what goes on in the artist
Studios let's see if Vincent mcgoke and
the art
will help to find the better ways to
overcome the profound spiritual social
and cultural crisis
we are living these days so what is it
that Freud can possibly teach us about
our present and our future well I think
there's quite a lot I believe that in
fact Western Civilization is in the
process of reaching its own limits
especially in ecological terms and
should decide whether it wants to revise
some of its own very premises for my
generation gen Z there won't be a future
of Western Civilization if governments
don't start taking cutting carbon
emissions seriously if we don't start
engaging in intergenerational discourse
because the generational divide has
grown very large I'm looking forward to
the next Nexus conference for a very
interesting discussion on inspiring
ideas of Frederick Nietzsche and Vincent
van Gogh
and I'm really hoping you're going to be
joining us as Nietzsche and Van Gogh
discuss the future of Western
Civilization hmm a pretty big topic and
one that interests me in particular from
the vantage point of religion
so to find out more about all this do
join us at the Nexus conference I hope
you will come to Amsterdam because I
will be there and I I'm sure there will
be some very exciting conversation
I do hope you'll be able to join us on
June 17th I hope to see you in Amsterdam
on June the 17th if you don't have a
ticket run out and get one right now we
really look forward to having you with
us hope to see you at the conference
I look forward to seeing you